today I've got this email it's from dr.
Kirsten Janish who is at the Columbia
University Medical Center and they've
asked us a question so I'll read a
little bit of the email dear Sirs I want
to congratulate you on your periodic
table of videos
dear Sirs yeah last time I checked I
wasn't so yeah this is on me I hope yeah
the reason of this email is the
following we recently found the
following book on amazon.com Landel
borns dying chemical shifts and coupling
constants for silicon 29 this costs
eight eight thousand five hundred and
thirty nine dollars which is pretty
steep for a book the questions there
they're asking and they're wondering how
how does this price came about and why a
book on silicon 29 and also what is so
special about silicon 29 well okay I can
I can try and answer those bits pieces
so okay so we'll start on what is so
special about silicon 29 - silicon 29 is
one of the isotopes of silicon it's one
of three naturally occurring isotopes of
silicon it's about 4.7 percent abundant
okay so the rest of it so you know 100 -
four point seven percent at the other
silicon isotopes which is 28 and silicon
30 now also special about silicon 29
which the other two silicon isotopes
don't have is that it has this property
called spin it's this nuclear spin
property allows us to get lots and lots
of information about the silicon so what
we can do is with silicon 29 is we can
put it into what we call an NMR machine
so NMR is a nuclear magnetic resonance
and if you talk to a lot most chemists
they tell you that the most sort of
powerful technique they can tell for
telling about sort of what's bonded to
atoms is this NMR spectroscopy so it
gives us lots and lots of clues about
about what's in our molecules that we're
looking at so let's so silicon 28 and
silicon 30 don't give you any
information about about the environment
and annum and you can't run any mass
spectra
on those isotopes but on silicon 29
because of this ratio of protons and
neutrons that we have in silicon 29 we
can get lots of lots of information
about them what these people have done
basically is they've got lots and lots
of data on hundreds I imagine I think I
looked it up this this is 463 pages long
this book so they've got tables and
tables and tables of data on all of the
properties so this chemical shift which
is I got a spectrum here is that this
isn't a silicon 29 but it's a proton NMR
spectrum so what they've done is they
collated lots and lots and lots of data
on thousands and thousands of compounds
and and put it into this book okay
so that's why silicon 29 is so special
the price comes about I imagine because
it's just such a specialist book you
probably only find it in a few libraries
and for the the the publishers and the
Authors to get any money back they
probably have to charge that that I'm at
a million libraries and and sort of
specialists would be prepared to pay
that sort of money so so yeah I I've
never spent that much money on a book
admittedly it's no Harry Potter but it
will be of interest to the people in in
their interests in silicon chemistry so
silicon is really really important in a
number of places it's really really
abundant in the Earth's crust so it will
come up in lots and lots of minerals so
silicate minerals and things and things
like that we also find it in things like
concrete and cement the electronics
industry obviously we've got Silicon
Valley so insulate sort of
semiconductors and things like that also
have a lot of silicon in them a lot of
the time but also things like silicones
okay so for example Brady's watchstrap
that he's wearing might well be made of
silicon obviously the silicon sealant
that you put around your bath and things
silicones come up everywhere they're in
baby's bottles lots and lots of plastics
you use will have silicones in them and
they're like organic silicon compounds
with oxygen bridges and they're really
really important so it's obviously very
very important to study
Silicon 29 animo
you